all right thanks to Joe Biden's weak
leadership America's enemies no longer
fear us and our allies no longer respect
us and it is more evident no matter
where you look around the world now the
leader of our oldest Ally France they're
now suggesting macron is suggesting that
Europe put some distance between itself
in the U.S so apparently they are ready
to fight their own battles now good we
won't have to worry about Europe the
continent they can handle but Crone can
handle what's going on in Ukraine and by
the way Egypt another supposed friend
who we send billions of dollars every
year to now they according to reports
they want to send missiles to Russia our
adversary to destroy the equipment that
we have spent and sent to Ukraine oh and
by the way the only reason we know that
because all about Egypt is because of
that massive leak of Highly classified
intelligence that Biden seems so
unconcerned about and has been unwilling
to show us and by the way not that
there's ever been any a good handling of
classified information remember Joe is
facing his own quote document Scandal
Congress is now finally going to get a
look at just how much damage his
carelessness may have done but none of
that can compare to the damage he's
allowed China to inflict on the entire
world the Chinese are now actively
rewriting the entire world order right
in front of all of us right under Joe's
nose taking full advantage of his total
lack of any and all influence on the
world stage and threatening any country
especially the U.S that dares to support
taiwan's right to Independence now they
bought American Farmland Ranch Land they
have bought it near several of our key
military bases they have flew that spy
balloon all across the entire country
they were in fact collecting sensitive
intelligence and sending it to China in
real time they let the world know that
they're ready for war with us on land
sea and by air and by the way now they
are signaling that Taiwan is next and
invasion is clear really imminent and
they're daring America to stop it and as
usual Joe Biden is doing nothing in
spite of all these threats here now with
more Florida Senator Marco Rubio is with
US senator good to see you all right I'm
glad you the gang of eight as you call
it are getting the classified
information that's going to be very
important here's my biggest concern and
and you know a lot more about this than
I do so when President Trump was in
office we had an alliance one that I
never thought I'd see in our lifetime
the U.S Israel the jordanians the
Egyptians the Saudis the Emirates I
didn't think I'd see that in our
lifetime but we had it all against
Iranian hegemony and a nuclear-armed
Iran that is now deteriorated and I
believe because the world has watched
and witnessed a cognitive mess as a U.S
president and for example Saudi Arabia
has now aligned itself with China China
brokered a deal between the Saudis and
the Iranians is now brokering a deal
between the Saudis and the Syria Brands
now we have Egypt where we send money to
they're going to be sending weaponry and
help to Russia uh to Aid in their battle
against Ukraine they were supposed to be
our Ally they get billions of our
dollars my question is this now from my
perspective I believe we are witnessing
a new Access of Evil emerge am I wrong
number one and number two uh am I wrong
in thinking Joe Biden is incapable of
dealing with it
so I mean Sean you just outlined a lot
of I was going to say look we have a
world that realizes we have a president
that can barely put together complete
sentences appears incoherent oftentimes
doesn't even know where he is in many
cases in some of these places that
allowed spy balloons to be flown over
our head that abandoned billions of
dollars of American military equipment
left over into the hands of the Taliban
and spends all day talking about
electric vehicles and solar panels that
he knows we're going to have to buy from
China we have a justice system that
indicts political opponents and former
presidents and leading presidential
candidates a justice system that
infiltrates sources and tries to spy on
Catholic churches but allows criminals
to destroy San Francisco and Baltimore
and Detroit and Washington DC and Los
Angeles and Manhattan You Name It We
have a military that doesn't spend its
time talking about new weapons systems
or how to care for veterans that are
committing suicides at historic rates
they spend their time talking about
transgender issues and all kinds of
racial disparity stuff not defending our
country we have a media that's become a
joke a media that's wasted two and a
half years of our time on a Russia
collusion situation then they moved on
from that to cover up the hunter Biden
situation it's now a full-blown
investigation our universities are a
forum for crazy things to happen you
can't even speak on a University campus
people being assaulted by men wearing
dresses and these violent protests and
shutting down speech and and and our
culture what is what we focused on as a
culture we're focused on the fact that
now some man pretending to be a woman
gets paid millions of dollars to sell
Nike sports bras and Bud Light so the
world looks at that and said this place
is a laughing stock and they react to it
and I could go on for an hour about all
the things that we are we are being
embarrassed on the world stage our
adversaries are taking advantage of it
and our friends are saying hey we may
have to go on on our own here because
these guys look like they're about to
commit societal suicide
let me ask you I'll read you some
headlines if I may uh Senator China
warns that its carrier killer missiles
will wipe out any U.S naval Force sent
to defend Taiwan one leaked intelligence
shows China's Hypersonic missile can
penetrate U.S air defenses three Trump's
EPA Chief is warning that Biden is
selling out U.S energy policy and
security to China for China declares
that its military is now capable of
Smashing Taiwan and they're even going
as far as to showing their battle plans
on state-run television of exactly the
targets that they plan to take out with
Taiwan and they're warning every country
and directly threatening the United
States that if we dare lift a finger to
help our Ally in the region that they
will Target us and they will destroy us
how do you interpret that yeah well I
interpret it two ways number one is that
there's a capability Gap that we have to
close we haven't invested in the things
we need to because we've been focused on
the Middle East we've been focused on
other parts of the world there are
things we're going to need to do to
create deterrence against China and
those systems that they're building but
one thing is ability and the other thing
is the willingness and I want to be
honest here okay I want I don't care if
you're a left-wing Democrat I don't care
if you voted for Democrats ask yourself
this honestly do we truly believe that
the Chinese Communist party and Xi
Jinping is intimidated by Joe Biden in
this Administration are worried about
them do we really think that guys I
think people need to be honest about
that this is not a president or an
Administration that commands respect
much less fear or or or concern on the
part of our adversaries that's why it's
no mistake that the Taliban moved in the
way they did and gave us 72 hours to
leave before they slaughtered Us in in
Afghanistan threatened to slaughter us
it's no coincidence that Putin moves on
Ukraine and it's no coincidence that
China's ramping all this up right now
this Administration looks like an
incompetent band of Fools and it is
embarrassing Us in the eyes of the world
and it is encouraging our adversaries
and it is causing our allies or former
allies or friends to say guys we can't
count on these people anymore they've
gone nuts over there they're destroying
their own country we better look out for
ourselves it's just real Senator Real
Talk you've said something really
profound they can't count on us anymore
uh I would make the argument and tell me
if you think I'm wrong that the Saudis
they made a calculation and the
calculation is is that China is going to
overtake the U.S as the leader the the
sole leader of the world that America
has abdicated its role in the Free World
and their place of leadership worldwide
so I think they made a decision they
want to be on The Winning Side so they
are now aligning with China I think
Egypt now has made the same Choice as
you know as I mentioned earlier their
their actions with Russia in respect to
Russia so my question is are they making
a conscious choice that they think the
winner of this quote new cold war that
this new uh axis of Evil as I'm calling
it Iran Russia and China that they're
going to be the victors here is that
their determination
I think the Saudis have said this the
Saudis mortal enemy or the Shia in Iran
and with the United States and here's
the United States trying to cut a deal
with Iran on nuclear weapons despite the
fact that Iran is trying to kill former
Trump officials and so what Saudi Arabia
saying is if you're going to cut a deal
with them we're going to cut a deal
before you cut a deal and we're going to
spread our risk so with Saudi Arabia
Egypt and countries all over the world
are doing now is they're Distributing
risk they want they want to deposit a
little bit of Goodwill and every bucket
to see how things turn on they are
basically hedging their bets because
they at least as long as Joe Biden is in
the white house they don't know what to
expect but they turn on the news and
they watch it and they read our
newspapers and all they read is
craziness from what happens to our
culture what's happening in our society
our universities our justice system the
administration our military you name it
there is no part of our country anymore
that has not been turned into a laughing
stock in the eyes of the world the
Catalyst of this is the radical left
that finds a home in this White House
and the people that have put in office
which embarrass us every day I believe
this new axis of of evil and I think the
choice of other nations that they're
going to bet on China and their new
alliance and their position of
leadership I think that they believe if
there's any conflict that China is the
more more likely to come out the Victor
do you agree with that do you think
America has the military might if
necessary nobody would ever want this to
happen to get into a military conflict
with China if we did if that did happen
would we lose do we have the Hypersonic
missiles they're bragging about every
day do we have the capability to stop
their Hypersonic missiles
well I think we still have very
significant capabilities but that
doesn't mean the Chinese won't go
anyways that's how important Taiwan is
to them but again none of your
capabilities matter in the eyes of the
Chinese if they don't think you have the
willingness to do it and look if the
United States wouldn't even tell the
Taliban look we were planning to leave
anyway but you're going to give us a
month because we have people and things
that we've got to get out of this
country and instead agreed to a 72-hour
ridiculous time frame that they gave us
to leave and left all that equipment
behind if we couldn't even handle the
Taliban a bunch of guys running around
you know wearing whatever it is they
wear these robes or whatever you think
the Chinese are worried about Biden
coming after them in a conflict like
this they question our willingness they
think our culture and our society is
broken and weak and they think the guy
in the White House and rightfully so
doesn't have the willingness to do any
of the tough things because he's too
focused on promoting some radical agenda
domestically and talking about outdated
things around the world when they even
make sense all right straight up
question if in fact that I believe it
will happen sooner than later uh China
goes and tries to take Taiwan and I
believe they will be successful do you
believe that the U.S that Joe Biden will
lift a finger to help them because I
don't believe he will
I think it the answer to your question
depends on who the president is do I
believe this Administration if it's just
what they're focused on on a daily basis
no I don't think that they would I hope
I'm wrong but I don't think that they
will I don't think that they will
because I think ultimately they'll be
caught by surprise they'll be limited in
their in their responses by a bunch of
different things including in their own
party and at the end it won't matter
because they won't be prepared to do it
they'll try everything possible and and
and by the way the leverage that they've
given the Chinese overs is more than
just military when you're saying that
you're going to build our entire energy
grid on things that the child that we
depend on the Chinese for how are you
going to possibly go to war with them if
they cut you off you don't we don't have
oil we don't have gas anymore because
you can't produce it under Joe Biden
we're going to have batteries and solar
panels made in China
that's all the leverage they need to
ensure that we don't get involved
security Wise from your perspective is
this the most dangerous time since the
end of World War II and the end of the
Cold War
without a doubt not only the most
dangerous the most important the 21st
century is being defined right now and
unfortunately the people in charge of
American foreign policy and domestic
policy for that matter are turning our
country into a laughing stock all right
Marco Rubio sadly I agree with that
assessment I think you're dead on right